hello friends i'm elena and welcome to
my channel where today i have something
pretty cool
sort of cool a bit chill i managed to
get my hands on
an xbox series x it's large
literally the size of my arm she uh she
got those fridge vibes but hey
there's little that i love more than
places that keep food so all jokes aside
i just wanted to make this very quick
video um as i have done with a couple of
games that i've had early access to in
the past
to basically say i have this thing if
you guys have any questions about it
please let me know
of course full disclosure microsoft sent
this to me um but i'm also not a
reviewer i don't do reviews
just a person who has this channel as a
hobby
in my spare time where i try to just
talk about cool stuff and enthuse about
video games with other people who like
video games this is for all intensive
purposes a preview unit i am able to
show you guys quick regime and um a
little bit of the ui i'll make a video
about that in the next couple of days
but generally speaking um my broader
impressions are under embargo
can't tell you the embargo date yet but
i will um likely have more coverage up
on this channel
uh soon i'm allowed to show you the
thing obviously
seriously shout out to the top like i've
seen this in photos but
it is really cool like the way that
anyway
i'm not allowed to talk about much more
than that yet
but yes this video basically exists so
that you guys can ask me any questions
you have about anything that you really
specifically want to know
and when that preview embargo is up i
can uh do my best to get through pretty
much all of those questions
kind of similar to how i've done videos
with gosu tsushima or in the last of his
part two but i try to just
literally find out what the questions
that you have that haven't been answered
are
and uh answer them to the best of my
ability as
technically as i possibly can so this is
a place for you to do that in the
comments below
that's all i can really say for now like
i said we'll have a video showing off um
some of the quick regime and
the different loading times between
different games as well as i'm testing
it out over the next few weeks
which is very exciting we'll just see
you soon
generally though i'm very excited to
jump into the next generation of gaming
with some beautiful new games with very
nice
load times alrighty everyone i'm alana i
will see you next time bye